name foods that go with peanut butter  bread  bread is not on the board  [Music]  what the [ __ ] do you think nobody said  bread  drop a fight  you'll find the website bro  listen talk to steve harvey bro don't  talk to me  oh my gosh revenge how does that feel oh  bread was not on that that is crazy  that's [ __ ] up peanut butter jelly  time peanut butter jelly time peanut  butter jelly peanut butter peanut butter  do you know why you laughing that much  it's on little jelly  it's number one  you know what the thing is  is i'm pretty sure you would have said  bread first no i said jelly oh okay yeah  i literally thought of jelly immediately  so go ahead when you use that bread i'm  like that's a good answer